hello everyone my name is jonas corla
i'm chief scientific officer at pacific
biosciences
and i would like to thank david smith
for inviting me to speak about the
latest applications of backfire
sequencing for clinical research as part
of the
virtual genetics week lab with so my
thanks to labrador's um
organizers as well i should mention that
pec bio products are for researchers
only and
are not for use in diagnostic procedures
so all them everything i'm going to talk
about
is for clinical research um this is the
agenda that of the topics that i'd like
to talk
to you today about i'd like to give a
brief introduction to the sql 2 system
and also hi-fi reads in case you're not
familiar and then give examples
particularly in the area of full-length
phase gene sequencing
and um you know realizing that the world
is now
very focused and for good reason of
course to the covet
19 pandemic i thought what i'd like to
try is to give these examples
with a view of particular types of
assays that have
relevance for understanding the host
immune response in particular and also
limited virus sequencing so i was hoping
to catch two parts of one stone by um
choosing these examples that you can
then
hopefully translate to your gene of
interest but
primarily now also highlighting the
utility
and the impact pec bio
assays with high fibres could have to
studying
the uh particularly the immune response
and the genetic disposition
to the coca-19 virus that we're all
trying to
combat so by way of introduction
um the pacquiao technology long-range
sequencing that most of you i assume are
familiar with over the last 10 years we
have
improved with regard to the overall
throughput and also read length
on the flipwood has increased by over 10
000 fold
since 10 years ago and the read length
were over 100 fold and this has been
accomplished both
through new software and sequencing
chemistries but also every five years or
so
through the use of new hardware and the
latest iteration of this
is the sql two system that we launched
pretty much
about a year ago it generates more data
because the smart cell 8m has 8 million
reaction wells compared to 1 million
before high fire reads i will get into
these are
accurate long reads and the higher
throughput
translates to faster results reduce
project time make it more affordable
and it supports a wide variety of
applications i'm just going to talk
about targeted sequencing in the area of
clinical research
so these hi-fi reits then are a new type
of data
that we we're very excited about and i
hope
i can share that with you and show you
that our researchers are also excited
about
and they break the paradigm of what has
been
the world until about a year ago where
you had
uh short and accurate reads on the one
hand and then long and noisy reads with
lots of errors
in on the other effect bio and oxygen
nanopore and so we have
now improved the chemistry sufficiently
that we can get
a very highly accurate beats that are
still very long and so this is
shown schematically here you have a
double stranded piece of dna
on the upper left hairpin adapters are
ligated and then when the polymerase in
smart sequencing
starts to make a copy and
we read the sequence information while
it's doing that
it will open up the structures into a
rolling circle synthesis mode
and you get these multiple subreads that
you see on the right and yellow and
purple
now those individually have errors and
they're indicated by the red
dots but those are random and so you
take the consensus from those individual
subreads as we call them
and you end up with what we call a hi-fi
reads that is
over 99 accurate that's how we define it
and so
that makes it really powerful to get
both the length and the accuracy
the best of both worlds and i will try
to highlight how this can be leveraged
for clinical research
before i give those examples i want to
highlight a few
differences that the long and accurate
reads
allow compared to short read or sender
sequencing
the first one is for amplicon sequencing
with regard to the primer design
uh so on the left you see that if your
insert that you're interested in gets
longer than let's say one kilobases you
have to walk yourself through that
with multiple pcr reactions and overlaps
and so forth
and it can become quite cumbersome and
in the case of short resequencing
you then sequence a lot and then you
have to stitch it together
that's different on the right with the
pec bio primer design because we have
the long read length
up to about 10 or even 15 kilobases
basically whatever long range pcr
amplicon you can make
we can sequence in one piece and
so that's a much easier design you have
one primer pair for target length up to
20 kb
and there's a greater primer design
flexibility
if there's a region in the genome that
doesn't give you a good primer that's
fine
just go 500 bases upstream or maybe a
kilowatt upstream doesn't matter
um to make the pcr work and uh it's it's
much
much a more simplified workflow and a
simpler asset design
similarly for structure variation many
of you are familiar that there's this
mlpa
assay and again it can be cumbersome to
develop these probes
um you need to test efficient probe
hybridization
ligations their potential dropouts
and it's difficult to identify inversion
events with the pec bio technology
again because we have the read length
you have one primer pair that
covers and phases all of these
structural variants
and give that within the same type of
data from the same
high fiber data and then lastly
on the assembly side of putting all the
data back together
i mentioned that if you have to walk
yourself through let's say a 6kb region
it can be cumbersome because you have
all these different reactions
and uh sequence reads that you have to
stitch together
no assembly is required with the
peculiar technology you get one long
read
whether it's one kv or six kb that's the
answer
and there's no assembly no downstream
bioinformatics are required
now lastly with regards to
multicollecting and bar coding
we have a number of different solutions
depending on
what particular target you have and
specifically how many
samples you have may
dictate what the best bar coding
strategy is
but we provide and let me start from the
bottom right
you can obviously put the barcodes into
the primers and
they already are on the amplicons or low
sample numbers you can use barcoded
adapters that only happens
and do that during the ligation and then
the two top approaches
are for larger sample numbers we realize
that
a very popular choice the m13 sequence
as
a linker between a two-step pcr protocol
where in the first pcr
uh you put on this linker and then in
the second you put on the barcodes in
the
universal uh pooled pcr setting we also
have universal primers or you can use
your own
and it's a very straightforward design
and this
easily will allow you to
barcode and pool over a thousand samples
currently with a standard setup
and then the software um
will analyze that automatically so we
have a set of 384 barcodes that are
optimized for smart sequencing
and then you can pool hundreds of
targets and samples
they will all because it's single
molecule sequencing
uh each reaction will give a single
molecule read that has
its own barcodes and the software will
de-multiplex that and then analyze that
in each barcode bucket
separately and give you the answer and
even higher multiplexes as possible
this is paul hebert on the upper right
who has championed this and has written
a very nice paper entitled the sequel to
sanger amplicon sequencing that scales
that i show on the left he's using
asymmetric
barcoding and pooling on the sql system
on the predecessor up to 10
000 amplicons and he finds that they're
not only more accurate
compared to sanger sequencing and the
workflow that he was doing until then
but also vastly more cost effective 40
fold less compared to sanger sequencing
and still an order of magnitude less
compared to next generation sequencing
he tested both alumina and ion torrent
and that's because you don't have to
stitch things together and have multiple
pcr reactions and so forth
and so um here's a comparison of the
workflow from the top that
was given by the researchers at growth
in canada
on the left you see their standard
workflow where after the initial
um uh amplification of the targets for
these
over 9000 specimens you have lots and
lots of different plates
in orange on the left where you have to
clean up and then pull it out
to get on the senger sequencer all of
that is no longer necessary
after the initial round of pcr and
putting the barcodes on you pull it into
one tube
you make one library you put it on the
sql system and all those specimens
will be sequenced simultaneously in just
one
smart cell reaction and so that was
developed on the sql system
now they have um already acquired the
sql-2 system it's the first in canada
and in the press release you see on the
bottom right there
with the oval green oval
showed some data now cooling 36 000
different specimens and running those on
one single smart cell so you can get to
extremely high
so in summary tech biosequencing
targeted
sequencing with tech bio is efficient
and quick and cost effective
both with regards to the library prep
the actual sequencing and the data
analysis
i won't go through those points
separately
there's also a link to a brochure that
you can look at
for more detail on the bottom here so
then
in the main portion of my talk i'd like
to give you examples
of where this paradigm has been
leveraged and as i mentioned
with a particular focus on genes and
regions in the human genome that have
relevance to the coca-19 pandemic
because they have roles in the immune
response before i do that i mean in
general
what we have seen is that with the hifi
reads
you can greatly improve the map ability
of
the information so this was uh on the
upper right is a paper
um highlighting about 200 or so
medically relevant genes that are were
called the so-called
ngs death zone so they were it was not
possible to sequence them
characterize them accurately and with
the high fire reads
um it's possible to get most of those
and uh detect for example five percent
more variance in the so-called medical
exome
um so just one example hidden there in
the list
in the green there is gba um so gpa
mutations therein
cause uh gaucher disease and uh
researchers from mount sinai
uh stuart scott this was a talk given by
bobby zebra
already in 2016 which is recorded and
you can
get the link full recording down here
showing that you can
now access the full gene with
smart sequencing and also characterize
the and resolve the pseudo gene so the
difficulty around
why this was previously in ngs death
zone
gene is because you have a lot of
polymorphism but also this nearby
pseudogene that has high homology so the
shorter reefs
don't tell you whether a particular
mutations on the gene
or in the pseudo gene and of course that
matters on with regard to the
disease presentation and so forth and so
they developed an assay that bobby also
described um sequencing an entire 6.4
kb piece of dna that covers the relevant
mutations you can identify the mutations
you can phase them into the two alleles
and so this um was quite a while ago
things take a while especially with new
technology but
this was late last year i believe was
approved by
the new york state department of health
as a
as a clinical test and so this is the um
this is the relevant um approved site
and highlighted there with smart
sequencing is now an approved clinical
test for
looking at gbi gene or comprehensive
grocery disease testing
and other genes are of
a similar nature and there are these
so-called heart
sequence genes and i've listed some of
them down there
this in particular for reproductive
carrier screening
it is anticipated that long-range
sequencing and high fibres will greatly
improve
characterization of these genes just
like gba
and ultimately increase and improve the
diagnostic yields
and this is a fairly uh large um
uh segment in the market um you can see
that right now
probably it's about a billion dollars
and worldwide and it's expected to grow
to about 3 billion in about 10 years
time
and so um we see great opportunities in
these areas
and um just as a screenshot and you can
pause the recording and look for your
favorite gene there are
a number of clinically relevant targets
that are
very exciting to us because we believe
they can be
sequenced better and more efficiently
with smart sequencing
and if you want to know more about this
two excellent review papers that
appeared last year
summarizing in the different areas
cancer reproduction and so forth
neurobiology
how long-range sequencing can help and
is emerging in
medical genetics but now a few examples
are relevant to corporate 19
the first one's ancient typing of course
the hla
gene family is one of the most important
genes in the immune response and so
typically this has been done with
shortbread sequencing with imputation
statistical imputation and for a few
years now it's been well recognized
that with pacquiao long reads it's a lot
easier to
segregate the alleles and to type hla at
high resolution and that's because you
can
generate long range amplicons that span
the entire all the exons and you can
phase the alleles
and it's much simpler more efficient
workflow
and you have direct evidence of new
alleles so no more imputation and so
forth
there's a very nice review article um by
lima mayer and steve marsh from anthony
nolan research institute in the united
kingdom
who have really pioneered um using pect
biosequencing
for high-resolution hla typing and this
is a
great review article from a while back i
was excited to see a very recent study
which came out just uh three weeks or so
on
looking at the hla e gene and applying
smart sequencing to
characterizing this particular hla gene
that's not been studied as heavily as
the others
and in the paper though you can see down
on the bottom
it is uh has been known to be involved
for example
in viral responses and cd8 t-cells
stimulation stimulation and so forth
so hlae may play an important role in
the immune system particularly in terms
of virus responses
and the hla e gene has previously been
assumed to have relatively low genetic
diversity
however the researchers sequenced 212
different samples and found
that 15 variants where a frequency is
less than one percent
indicating that it is possible that um
there are many hlae
alleles with low frequencies in the
population opposing the historical view
of the
hle diversity and suggests that we'll
find more variation and it may have
effects on the immune response and the
virus response
and then the last sentence is you can
see however when reporting novel alleles
care should be taken of using shortbread
dna sequencing technologies
advocating for smart sequencing to
really do this
correctly um there are service providers
here's
one example nazi syrup on the right has
been championing
pec bio for um hla sequencing service
and of winning multi-year contracts to
do this
uh this was in 2018 when he had already
tested
about a half a million samples by now
it's well over a million samples that
have gone
into high volume high resolution hla
typing lab that he's running and
really setting the new gold standard and
then in addition to histogenetics
i mentioned anthony nolan lab course
also a site where you can get hla typing
done with picfio
and i have some of the contact
information if you're interested and
have cohorts that you would like to
subject to
really knowing what the hla types of
those samples
are with confidence the second area is
in the area of pharmacogenomics
so the problem statement is very simple
that of course people have different
responses to different drugs
and also the drug amounts so the
medicines that are being applied have to
be carefully tailored to each individual
patient
but that's difficult without knowing the
genetic disposition
and so 3.5 percent of hospital
admissions are related to adverse drug
reactions and it's actually in the us
the fourth uh leading cause of death
adverse drug reactions
um knowing about uh the types of genes
that are responsible for metabolizing
those
medicines better is very advantageous
here's just one example there are many
others that are being now sequenced with
pec bio
2d6 is a classical gene that's
metabolizing a large number of drugs
western medicine drugs and in a series
of papers by different groups
you can see from the titles full length
sequencing of
2d6 being flexible and scaling allowing
for new
allele discoveries and now getting into
the clinical pharmacogenomic
pharmacogenetic testing
arena in this article on the lower right
and lastly i want to talk about the
immune related
sequencing so our particular you know
this applies to any
challenge of the human immune system but
with regard to
star score v2 um you know how could
hypersequencing potentially help
understand the host response
so what we've seen there in general is
that
full-length b-cell repertoire sequencing
can be of
utility to find the broadly neutralizing
antibodies and recovered patients and
find out what they are
differentiate effective from ineffective
immune responses and
also for vaccine response testing and
then with regard to the
genotypic disposition which obviously
may influence the disease progression
sequencing the igh locus in the genome
which has been uh very difficult so i
would like to give a couple examples of
this
broad application area so with regard to
b
cell receptors many of you will be
familiar so very briefly recap
you have this diversity through vdj
recombination that
creates the initial receptor diversity
you have slot splicing which adds to bcr
diversity and then you have somatic
hypermutation
which can introduce even more variants
and they can occur
anywhere in the variable region not just
the cd3
and so on the right you can see that if
you're only sequencing the cd3
a cdr3 the short reads you're missing
important variants and high varies allow
you to get the full resolution of
both the variable and the constant
region so the short read approaches
only capture variants within each
section of what's relevant
hi-fi reads can capture all the
mutations that arise during somatic
hyper mutations
and they capture the isotype information
some single molecules and the accuracy
and consistency is very high
because there's no assembly required you
get the full read
and that is the entire uh information
you don't have to
stitch together short pieces so
a uh i think a landmark pioneering paper
in 2016
uh was published um that is called
artisan pcr rapid identification of
full-length immunoglobulin
rearrangements with our primer finding
bias
by kerning and all are really nicely
demonstrating that
you can now get on these full length
regions
um and see those rearrangements all vdj
alleles are amplified with equal
efficiencies
and that's because the rt and the pcr uh
priming occur
exclusively in the constant domain so
you don't have to do any
amplifications in variable domains which
introduce bias
there's no assembly required so it's
very consistent and
the accuracy is being very high
including for longer rearrangements
and all the variants are captured
instead of only those in the
city of korea region uh here's an
example comparison
uh in black uh the new artisan pcr
um and with regards to the homology
and you can see that the multiplex rt
pcr
fails because you can have mismatches in
primary binding sites
uh lack of a primer for certain alleles
or truncations of genes
and that results in a bias
and uh so the paper demonstrates that
this article pcr combined with the
massively parallel long-resequencing
technology with pectio
that covers the entire vdj sequences in
a single read
that's uniquely provided by the platform
permits an
unbiased and comprehensive analysis of
the bcr repertoires this paper was
applying it to cancer but obviously it's
straightforward to imagine
applying that to viral infection and the
immune response to viral infection
like uh um the current pandemic causing
virus
coronavirus uh now then uh switching
over to the genetic disposition the igh
locus
has been really difficult to resolve and
that's because it is
highly repetitive and corey watson and
colleagues melissa smith
at mount sinai they have pioneered smart
sequencing to really resolve
these loci so previously
sequencing the igh locus and genotyping
it required back cloning and sanger
sequencing
or relied on statistical inference from
immune repertoire data
and so the researchers here uh pioneered
pec bio
specific ethnic specific reference
genomes that have fully assembled igh
loci
reveal all the structural variation of
the igh locusts that you can see an
example thereof
on the left and uh we understand that
corey watson and colleagues are now
following up with the target capture
method to sequence large number of
samples
using hyper supposing the first work was
done in the context
of whole genome sequencing and now
getting this to a target capture method
will
make it very efficient and compatible
with a large number of samples
um recently corey watson uh collaborated
with others
to um generate this tool immunotyper
um calling tool uh genotyping
and uh performing copy number variant
and copy number
copy number analysis of the
immunoglobulin
heavy variable genes are using the
pectoral weeds
and this is from the abstract i've just
highlighted that
one of the remaining challenges in
describing
an individual's genetic variation is the
igh locus
and on the other hand it's critical for
the development of antibodies in the
adaptive immune system so for
coronavirus responses for example
the neonatal calling tool is the first
biobased genotyping
copy number calling tool specifically
designed
for these ighb genes and it's
this paper presents the most
comprehensive genotyping approach
published today
so check out this paper and then also in
model organisms this is a preprint
that i understand has not been accepted
for publication in the journal of
immunology so it should come out very
shortly
um looking at rhesus macaques
of course the macaque is an important
model organism for
immune disease research such as hiv zika
but now
um i would imagine also kobe 2
for certain but the immune replica
database for macaque is
incomplete and not the best quality um
so in this paper
um this is a nice and sick paper
full-length rna-seq
uh pooling different tissue types and uh
carrying out full transcriptomization
and in summary
the paper presents the first full-length
complete reference set
of all major ig and tcrg families in the
macaque genome
it profiles the sequence diversity in
the variable regions
reveals pcr amplification bias with the
existing macaque primers and
design the first vdj primers for the
resistance cover
that is then also applicable um
to follow for single cell platforms
which is very exciting
so then closing the circle and thinking
about sequencing the virus that's also
just
also amplicon based sequencing because
it's an rna virus
and the standard approaches are to make
cdna
and then to sequence these amplicons we
have
generated a website a resource web page
that you can see the link
um on the lower right techy.com sports
live coverage 19.
um looking at long insert amplification
rather than
the 400 base short read inserts and the
longer amplicons could be advantageous
because they can be they can span
a longer stretch of the virus sequence
it seems like at the moment the virus
may be not
mutating very much however it is
certainly anticipated that that
can change once uh it is challenged
with drugs um for example
and then drug resistance mutations um
would be selected for and so forth and
so um there have been a number of long
insert
strategies that have already published
from the cdc
liverpool australia mount sinai we're
also working on our own
design to capture the virus in bigger
chunks and bigger pieces
and so check out the uh the website and
um
phasing mutations and looking at minor
variants is certainly something that has
been applied
already quite extensively on other
viruses
so here is just a few examples of hiv
hepatitis b virus and so forth and the
last one on the bottom
you see is another coronavirus human
coronavirus nl63
and doing surveillance and looking at
recombination history and so forth so
this is all things that you can
very easily do with the hifiri paradigm
and and take it to the single cell level
so this is a really exciting
paper in the journal neurology looking
at flu and
um bio single cell isoscept data
you have both the full length influenza
virus sequence and the immune response
transcripts
and so this allows you to get a
comprehensive view
of the mutation landscape in each cell
and showing for the flu for example
we know that there's extremely high
mutation rates and recombination rates
and this study is the first complete
picture of how viral mutations
affect the course of infections in
single cells
so with that i will close and um i hope
i've given you an example for the
benefits of an overview
with examples of the benefits that smart
sequencing can provide for amplicon
sequencing
uh simplified workflow cost effective
reduced time to results on the sql 2
system
and the highest accuracy and resolution
through the use of hi-fi reading
for most amplicons which are short the
reads are
essentially always perfect greater than
qv50
also greatly simplifying the
bioinformatic analysis
there's lots of other information on our
website
and there are some of the links here
that you can see
and get from the pdf that will be
distributed from our website
both with regard to best practices
applications procedures and checklists
as well as posters and webinars on uh
related
topics so with that i'll close i would
like to uh thank david again
for allowing me to speak and his um uh
clinically focused
forum as part of the virtual genetics
week at laughwoods i'll thank you for
attending
and i understand that you can put
questions in the
question panel and those will be emailed
to me
and i'll be very happy to answer those
and look forward being in touch
and if you're interested in pack
biosecurity please visit our website
thank you very much